this is search engine optimization
fundamentals
site design and architecture provided by
matt bailey president of site logic
it's very interesting i've spent many
years in
web development companies and i've
always been fascinated with the web
development process and typically what's
happened is a company will go to a web
developer or web designer and say we
need a new website
and what happens is about a week or two
later the web development company comes
back with a couple of pretty pictures
and the business is then
asked to pick which picture they like
the most
and what happens is the artist tends to
direct the web development process
and it's more focused on a pretty
picture
rather than being focused on the primary
needs of the customer
and what happens is
the site rarely meets the business
objectives that the company has
see rather than sitting down and
focusing on what makes that business
money who their customers are and how
they think and react and doing all the
keyword research ahead of time
they run right ahead and start
decorating the house rather than
building the house
and that's where if you're designing a
site need to focus more on the function
what makes you money as a company
and then how do you step backwards from
that and develop a site that is focused
on meeting your needs as a business
which is being profitable
and then go and after you have completed
the functions
the necessary elements and the primary
elements of
how do we convert people how do we get
them to do what we want them to do how
do we ensure that we make money with
this site and that it does what we want
it to do
after those elements are taken care of
then you design in the window dressing
and all the things that make it pretty
but first and foremost it has to be
functional with the primary goal of
benefiting the business with additional
sales leads and of course profit
so we've got to really
design the house before we decorate it
and that's what this section is going to
be focused on is how search engine
optimization can assist
in providing a great framework for
marketing the site overall and focusing
it to the right means